Tal Brown,  Zone7,
thank you for joining me.
My pleasure.
Thank you for having me man.
You know, it's so cool because in all
my social media, I wrote you
on all my contacts as Tal Brown Zone7
and your Zoom link says that as well.
So, from now, like your company
is attached to your name.
It's a part of your identity.
You know why?
Because I read somewhere a while ago
that to add your company name
to your Google account name will mean that
every time somebody sees an e-mail
or you log in, it will say,
Tal Brown Zone7.
So, I did that and I forgot about it.
And now it's everywhere.
And now you can never rebrand
no matter what do you do.
For me, you're gonna be
Tal Brown Zone7.
Tal, what is Zone7?
What is this thing?
Zone7 is software,
that is artificial intelligence software
that helps you make decisions about
how hard to push yourself physically.
When to rest.
When to train harder.
With the objective of
performing at your peak for longer.
Right.
And in sports, it means less injuries,
dramatically less injuries.
Staying in that peak shape
for longer and longer periods.
Amazing. So, for me,
that's a fascinating field.
My girlfriend just finished at Stanford.
She actually just won
the national championship
in soccer as a striker.
And I know that that is very
relevant to what you're doing.
And it's very relevant
because one of the main things
that she was telling me
was that it's incredible how many
injuries they have on the team.
And she's explaining to me
how they pushed them physically
throughout the trainings.
And honestly, it's not that surprising
that half of her team
is constantly in some sort of injury.
But, Tal, tell me about zone7.
How do you use AI and software
to help reduce the injuries?
Well, when somebody gets injured,
something breaks down.
Maybe they were pushed a little bit
beyond their limit for that day. Right?
And your limits change, right?
You could do something on a Monday
you couldn't do on a Tuesday.
And it's really hard to figure out
that limit because it changes
from day to day.
And it depends on a lot of stuff:
It depends on your sleep,
and on your nutrition,
and on your current workout
and previous workout,
how well you recover it
and all that stuff.
And so, for one person looking after
20, 30 athletes, like a soccer team,
solving that puzzle
for every single player every day
is really complicated.
And as a technology
in the technology sector,
there's a couple of things we've done
over the years to help.
The first thing is to collect data.
So, we've helped collect data.
We've got sensors on the backs of
soccer players and basketball players
and hockey players
that measure movement and running,
sprinting and jumping.
So, we're collecting data
about sleep as well and all that stuff.
The second thing we're doing is
we're helping visualize the data.
So, we've got all the Excel,
spreadsheets, and we've got the CRMs,
and we've got the tableaus.
We can plot every single parameter
that we have about you.
But what we haven't done really well
is to enable accurate interpretation
of the data.
Right.
And what I mean is that,
what is your trend mean today?
How does that relate to
other soccer players of your age
that have been injured in the past?
Right.
What should you do?
It's not just about red flag.
You know, we should give you advice
on how to tweak your training.
How far can we push you
without breaking you?
You know, I love this so much because
I was an athlete myself.
I played varsity tennis and volleyball
in high school.
And one, I think it's not just about
a trainer being accountable
and looking at the 20 players
and measuring them on a daily basis
and knowing how to push them.
But the promise that you're attaching
emotions into the training.
And when you have a game coming up,
you may be blinded
by putting in the extra effort.
Yeah, what are the chances
they can handle it?
They're just crybabies.
They can do it.
When you're talking about software,
and when you're talking about just data
that's giving the feedback.
It doesn't take into account
that you have a game tomorrow.
It merely looks at the statistics and says,
based on your current assessment,
you're prone for an injury, right?
Yes and no.
So that the cold data
does not understand schedules
and does not understand emotion.
But today what we do is
it's not just about the data.
It's about understanding
your weekly schedule.
Is this a Tuesday?
Is this a Wednesday?
Is this a Thursday?
Are you playing on a Saturday?
Who are you playing?
What's a typical game against
those opponents look like for you?
What are the demands that we think
you will need to do
in order to win on that game?
So there's that context.
And in soccer specifically
it's called the Microcycle.
A weekly cadence of getting ready
for a game on the weekend.
Basketball's a bit different.
Baseball as well,
because they're playing more.
But it's the same principle.
That's basically making sure
you're peaking for a game
and then letting you recover
and train hard in between.
And as for emotions.
I do not like to speculate
about emotions but
today you've got products
that are available
for a couple of hundred bucks
that take very good measure
of your recovery,
of your stress,
of your heart rate
when you're resting or sleeping.
And that doesn't differentiate
being angry versus being upset
versus being sad.
But it does measure very accurately
how your body is responding
when you're not training.
So, we can call it
recovery data or wellness data,
but it is hard data.
And if we understand what a
typical recovery for you looks like,
that allows you to perform
a really good game.
Then we can see if you're there or not.
And we can help calibrate that
on a day to day basis.
Tal, coming from somebody who doesn't
really follow sports actively,
now I'm following because of Carly.
But for somebody who's not
really following actively,
it doesn't seem like injuries
are that prevalent.
Because I'm seeing Messi
go on the field every game
and Ronaldo is playing every game.
And so, but I know that it's a big deal
because you're going after
a big market and therefore,
I trust you.
But Tal, give me a little bit of a rundown.
What is the scope of injuries
that we're seeing today in sports?
So, I think you're getting a biased view
of how big the problem is
just because of your,
maybe it's also timeline,
because of covid,
less sports in North America.
But you look at what's going on
in the UK, in Europe right now?
Dozens of players are
down with injuries.
Arsenal had seven injuries
in like two weeks of games.
These are devastating, right?
The difference between
winning and losing over a season
can be one or two injuries.
And you look at Messi,
there's a little study that
sometimes I referred to,
he was down for about six weeks,
I think it was two years ago.
But if you look at the number of points
per week that Barcelona were able to get
with and without him, it's measurable.
So, about 20 to 30% of a soccer squad
is out every given moment.
Really? 20 to 30%?
And is that mostly stress related?
Or is that mostly,
because of collisions and whatnot?
So, it's basically about two thirds,
70% are what's called
soft tissue injuries.
So, not contact related.
Wow.
So, pulling your hamstring,
tearing your ACL, groin, ankle
and some of it is contact.
But I'll tell you this.
Contact injuries,
while we cannot predict what happens
when two people collide fast
on a soccer pitch or a hockey ice rink,
contact often aggravates
an existing issue.
Huh.
So, not to say it's predictable,
but to say that if you can quantify
how strain certain things are,
then the likelihood of contact
to bring you over the tipping point
for an injury is greater.
So, it's a huge problem
and it's huge in sports.
You look at the NBA finals last year.
Determined on both sides,
by one side being extremely healthy,
on the other side being
extremely unlucky after five years
of phenomenal success with injuries.
But for us as a company,
sport is a first market.
If you look at a wider field
of employers and employees,
people who are under physical
and mental stress for living,
that market is even bigger, right?
Messy, you wanna help messy.
You wanna help Durant.
You wanna help Tom Brady.
But ultimately, you've got doctors
working under extremely difficult
mental conditions in hospitals.
You've got oil and gas workers
under a lot of stress.
You've got manufacturing, factories.
That's actually the point.
So, for us, that's the horizon.
And we're already deploying
using our success in soccer
and hockey and baseball
to deploy into environments
like ERs and still working plans.
I have to say that is so cool.
When we met for the first time
a few months ago,
and I was so inspired
by what you're doing.
It's because I was reflecting back
on my experience in the
Eilat Desert Marathon of 2017.
And it's such a monumental moment for me.
Both because I managed to finish it,
but also, because
it was a disastrous moment for me.
Because since then
I've been dealing with knee problems.
And almost every person
that I talked to told me,
"Michael, you're gonna injure yourself."
"You don't know what you're doing."
"You're gonna push your
body past what it can do."
I had no contact injury.
I didn't mess up at any point.
I finished the marathon.
I was feeling great.
I went into my ice bath
and I couldn't get up.
My body just couldn't handle the stress
of running all that distance.
And I think to myself
that when I said emotions before,
that was my mental state that
I was ignorant enough to not listen
to the doctors and the therapists
because I thought
I didn't really believe them.
But if I had data that showed me,
Michael, based on your training
and based on the training of others
who got injured in long distance running,
we think you're at risk.
I think that that would give me much
more confident than listening
to a trainer who I think might have,
maybe something against me
or doesn't really want me to succeed.
So, I think trainers
are extremely important.
Because ultimately,
software doesn't understand you.
We don't hear your voice.
We don't understand your emotions.
There's a lot of stuff we don't capture.
Not to say we can't.
So, we're really helpful
with the data stuff.
But ultimately, a trainer is important.
It's kind of like a pilot, right?
Inventing GPS did not
get any pilot fired.
It just gave him a really good
navigational tool.
Instead of looking at the stars
as they're crossing the Atlantic
trying to figure out
if this is the right way.
Right.
So, trainers will continue to be there.
But we're just gonna give them
better and better tools.
And in a sense of detecting risk,
they're gonna have a compass that's gonna
be super accurate all the time.
That's where we're headed, right?
We're not gonna get rid of trainers.
But we will get rid
of certain grey areas
where people make biased decisions.
Think about stock trading, right?
30 years ago,
probably stock traders would have said,
"There's no way computers could do this
better than we could."
Right?
And today nobody on his right mind
would consider not using some
kind of automated system to that.
So, sports is changing as well.
A little bit slower or a little bit after
some other industries,
but it's gonna happen.
Tal, I think that's so cool.
I wanna hear about your background.
How do you get to do something like this?
You move from Israel to Palo Alto,
a part of UpWest Labs that are
so kindly sponsoring the series.
I mean, how do you even get
to build an AI software for sports?
So, my story is somewhat unique
in the sports technology field.
I'm not a sports guy.
I didn't play. I didn't train.
I didn't treat players. Didn't manage players.
I spent my early careers
in Israel's [--]
creating big data products
for the intelligence community.
Then I spend some time at Salesforce.
I was one of the first
product managers at Salesforce
to work on predictive technology.
This isn't a time where 2012, '13,
nobody wanted to hear about this.
I was kicked out of meetings
for about a year.
We will never do AI.
We're not that kind of company,
Go back to your dreams in Tel Aviv.
And the world changed.
And I was on that journey with Salesforce.
So, I learned how to create products
that use machine learning to help,
I would say non-technical people,
not scientists or engineers,
do their job better and faster.
How do you measure
the success of this product?
How do you build it?
How do you craft it?
How do you visualize recommendations
to a user who is not a scientist?
Right.
So, I did that for a living.
And it was a great journey,
Salesforce is an incredible company.
And then I tell you, the stars aligned.
I wanted to do my thing.
I wanted to start a company.
I met my co-founder
who is a sports scientist,
a phenomenal talent.
And we had a pilot.
We had two pilots in Israel, right?
And if you know Israel, you know,
there's a lot of good
stuff about Israel.
But it's not a sports superpower.
It is not a sports superpower.
That is definitely not.
But we got lucky.
We got lucky because one of the only
real sports VIP is in Israel,
Jordi Cruyff,
who used to coach Maccabi
and is a very famous soccer player.
He was coaching the team
that we had a pilot with
and he saw it and he said,
"Oh, this is working."
"Contrary to what I was led to believe
my entire life about soccer injuries."
And he said,
"All right, I'm going to help you guys."
"And I'm going to join the company
as an adviser investor."
And the next thing that happened
was meeting UpWest.
And basically, it's glad
they're also sponsoring me.
They were the first firm,
the first investor to say,
"This could be big."
"We believe in this."
"You're gonna play by our rules."
And that means get yourself
to Silicon Valley,
spend some time with us here,
because the more time you spend
in the market you wanna grow in,
the more likely you are to succeed.
It's not a guarantee.
It's just, it just makes sense.
So, I literally quit my job.
Signed a paper with UpWest.
And a couple of days later,
I was on a plane.
And I left my wife and my two kids
in Israel for four weeks at a time,
coming to here to work,
to connect, to build the company.
Really?
Yeah. So, I did like pretty brutal,
like army style.
Like four weeks [--]
to one or two weeks at home
for about 18 months.
And then once we gonna got us,
Yeah. So, the big hero here
is my wife.
And we can do a whole podcast
about my wife.
Of course.
And then 18 months later
we had a seed round.
And I relocated the entire family
to Palo Alto.
So, it's been a crazy journey.
Somewhat crazy in the sense
of like just living really weird life
for a while.
But I've seen the company grow,
which is phenomenal.
I'm seeing more investors coming in.
I'm seeing more success.
So, I gotta say, the UpWest thesis
is definitely something that I believe in
very strongly.
Tal, that's just incredible.
And your daughter goes
to the same elementary school
that I went to,
which is the most exciting part
of this whole conversation,
I have to say.
Because I have such a phenomenal
childhood here across the street and
No dragon.
No dragons. And I'm actually
I'm really jealous of her.
The handball wall
there is two handballs.
And that's where I spent
my entire elementary school.
So, if she ever needs tips
on how to win there.
I know all the dirty tricks of this game.
Well, this kid came into here last summer,
didn't speak a word of English.
And yesterday she read to me
Green Eggs and Ham
right before she went to bed.
So, we talk about AI in sports.
But kids have it just like that.
Effortless learning.
I think it's a wonderful gift
that you are giving her.
For me, growing up more of an
international background
and going back and forth
and having both the Israeli mindset,
but also, the American mindset.
They complement each other
with all their differences.
That I think it makes for something
very very special.
If you want, I can do the Israeli interview.
But up to you.
Exactly. Tal, reflect with me
on the startup journey.
Now that you have great traction,
you're going and you're deploying
this in different spaces.
I didn't even know that you're going now
into places that are not just sports,
which is I think it's incredible.
What advice would you give
to young entrepreneurs,
perhaps young entrepreneurs
out of [--].
They're working on
building their software.
Their market may be here,
but it's not that easy to make the move
and pick up the family
and go to Silicon Valley.
So, what advice would you give
to these entrepreneurs?
Well, I'll say a couple of things.
First of all, I did this a little bit later
in my career.
So, on one hand, I had a family
which was a great great force
of stabilization for my life.
On the other hand,
I had more tools in my first
professional toolbox.
I work in Salesforce.
I was a PA and I did sales before.
So, I had maybe to tell you
but a little bit differently than
if I would be like 25, 26.
So, I would say this, first of all,
don't be scared to spend
another couple of years in your career
working for a company.
Just be sure to spend it
where you think would be
the most ROI for your future.
So, don't just go to a job,
work with friends.
Because we're the guys from the middle
and whatever.
Know, and so many people
I feel are looking for jobs
because of the difference
in a few thousand dollars a year.
Look, it's like chess.
You don't have to look
15 years down the road.
Look three years down the road.
What's gonna best prepare you
for that next thing?
And for me,
the product management experience
and the Salesforce experience
as an American innovative company.
That was huge for my career.
So, that's one.
Plan a little bit ahead.
Don't be scared to work
for a couple of years.
Nothing's gonna happen.
I started my company, let's say,
more than 10 years after I finished
more [--]
So that's one.
Number two is, aim big.
Go to the US. Right?
Our place is a phenomenal fund.
They're not the only way to do it.
But the more time you spend here,
your thinking is going to change.
It doesn't mean an Israeli ecosystem
is not a phenomenal.
But regardless of the identity
of your investor,
come to the US
spent as much time as you can here.
It's really weird in the beginning,
but it pays dividends later.
I'm sure.
And the third thing is really,
it's obvious but it's so true.
It's resilience.
You've got to be prepared.
You're gonna be in a mental space
where you're okay with
getting slapped on the face
or getting rejected 100 times a day.
Not to say that happens every day,
but it does happen occasionally.
So, you've gotta be on your feet.
You've gotta be happy in the journey.
And you've gotta push forward
because there will be hard days.
You gotta be ready for it.
You've gotta want it right.
So, resilience is really important.
And like I use it, somewhat a metaphor,
A sword doesn't become strong
just because it's a sword.
It becomes strong
because it gets hit
with boiling hot hammers
a thousand times.
So, 10,000 times.
So, that's how you forge a sword.
So you've got it.
That's the process.
Tal, I love it.
20 minutes go by so fast.
I have to know the most
important question,
three words that you would use
to describe yourself or
that Shuly and Gil, our friends
would use to describe you.
So,  I'll say, Dad.
I'll say Third Culture Kid as one word
because it's one concept.
And I'll say,
well, good one.
I think Courageous as a word,
not that I'm great
but I’ve learned to jump in the water
when it's really hard.
That's the most important I think.
It's incredible.
And I mean that's the trade
that allows you to go and explore
whatever you wanna do.
All right Michael.
Good luck with your journey.
You're doing phenomenal work.
And thank you UpWest for sponsoring this.
Tal, toda raba. Really amazing.
And I can't wait for dinner in August,
September, whenever that happens,
whenever this whole thing comes down.
All right. Take care. See you soon.